Bella a tutti ragazzi E bentornati su
Resident Eagle for siamo all'episodio 3
Spero che vi piaccia Buona visione e vai
o no per il capitolo number three
ragazzi Mamma mia come stiamo andando
spediti pronti
[Musica]
stasera
avrei dovuto lasciarlo marcire in quel
sacco
Ti invio tutti i dettagli da un'occhiata
ma aquila reale è la priorità va bene
ricevuto Mi dirigo verso la chiesa Ah
adesso devo tornare indietro Porca [__]
vero dottorandi villaggio ragazzi tanto
è diventata notte fuori adesso è peggio
di prima Ah Proviamo a vedere se fuori a
parte il fatto che c'è ancora quello
della motosega però è buio quindi
teoricamente
se n'è andato era qua quello con la
motosega se n'è andato via perfetto amo
Aspetta che non so se si apre sta porta
qua ho trovato una porta con lo step
Eh non mi maltrattate cani vi ammazzo Eh
no poverino che è successo tesoro Vieni
qua c'è benzina bravo
ho dell'erbetta per quella Gambetta Eh
te la dovrei mettere a posto
teoricamente Oh che bello che
Dov'è Oh attenzione amico
motosega e fa attenzione Tu manco un
grazie Comunque vabbè adesso ciò sta a
chiave teoricamente dovrei usarla qua
perfetto
arrivederci Ma se tornassi indietro la
chiesa dalla strada dove sono arrivato
ci arriveremo No non ci arrivo perché mi
hanno trascinato fino qua quindi non so
neanche come ci sono arrivato di quasi
passa Dovrei riuscire a tornare in un
posto che conosco da qualche parte
Ah siamo arrivati al villaggio Minchia
ma che culo perfetto
Porca [__]
Sì ma anche meno raga eh Cioè non è che
che succede Oh ma che cazzo è oh oh oh
ho riparato tuo fratello prima testa di
culo ma che vuole entra entra dentro
entra dentro No è chiuso Non ci credo
sono morto Cazzo no vabbè Raga non ci
voglio credere ma che è
che cazzo ci fanno dei cani così grossi
qua fuori
donna che paura ragazzi Ma cosa devo
fare qua Non lo so ragazzi Mica sono
tantissimi
mori mori
date una [__]
Ok
sono morti tutti poi avere la spada
danno anche un botto di roba perfetto Oh
No
Dagli incazzotto Ma minchia
Meno male che non ci credo
Meno male che non durano tanto regà se
no ero già stecchito da Nora Madonna che
male Porca [__] poi mi devo curare
ragazzi che sono Schioppo c'era
veramente
si fa duro al cazzo cioè io devo farlo
io non è che
Madonna ma poi è crollato tutto sto
casino che cosa che che è successo qua
come è crollato sto campanile Random ho
crollato un Campanile
sento rumore che non mi stanno piacendo
Sento rumori che non mi sa c'è una bomba
sta succedendo Eh perché sento sti
rumori perché c'è una bomba qua piano ma
lo posso disinnescare senza ah ah
non devo sparargli per fare che ne so io
regà che ne so queste fanno le trappole
con col culo Oh
c'è questa questa ha messo sulla
trappola e poi è rimasta lì ferma ad
aspettarmi proprio stronzo sei magari
qua va
Eh vabbè ragazzi da dove arriva tutto
sto casino qua Cioè non c'era tutto sto
bordello prima
questo mi sa che lo devo far fuori prima
che si rialzi vero Ecco perfetto lo
sapevo io Mannaggia è morto è morto è
morto a posto Mi sono preso i colpi la
pistola che gli ho sparato a lui va bene
vi vedo competitivi ragazzi e Rispetto a
prima vi vedo molto competitivi la cosa
mi mi piace Uh forse lo posso far fuori
così però non coltelli eh
non ho col coltello Vabbè facciamo così
Cioè più o meno comunque la stessa cosa
e muori ok
tanto ormai entriamo qua dentro stiamo
per entrare in una nuova area che
comunque non capisco come mai mi faccia
salire tipo nel nell'appartamento di
prima dovevo salire con due persone da
solo non ce la facevo però siamo entrati
in una nuova area Quindi sta cosa non me
la spiego
Quindi potremmo ancora tornare indietro
in tutto sto casino a quanto pare Oh
ma vattene a [__] Minchia Ma ragazzi
solo studiati jumpscarin 'sto geni sto
Resident Evil Ma come cioè rispetto agli
altri video infarti Cioè ma sto male
giuro Cioè ma che cazzo minchia c'è un
teschio un po' grosso lì va bene
al Lord Sadler salvalore server questo
Lord Sandler è uno strunz bastardo che
però scopriamo più avanti Per adesso
tutto ok
che Madonna che cazzo di chi minchia è
'sto teschio qua Guardate che non si
svegli lui Ma cos'è qua
spray medico Nice
c'è qualcos'altro qua dentro abbiamo
tutto ok Mi stanno preparando a una
Fight Eh ragazzi lo vedo però nel mentre
noi andiamo sempre con un sacco di
ottimismo giorno
il mio ragazzo preferito Poi cosa c'è
qua stanco di restare sempre senza
munizioni lancia la freccia la vera
rivoluzione può recuperare riusare le
sue come the forest va bene se sto tizio
che potrebbe piacere
in inglese però Benvenuto va bene lo
stesso ci avevo pensato anche l'altra
volta nel Lancia frecce articoli in
offerta eh anche in offerta Cioè va bene
va bene Mi hai convinto sei stato siete
stati degli ottimi influencer mi avete
convinto la potenza del fucile a pompa
Raga ma io lo userei No perché ragazzi
Io lo uso nelle boss Fight c'è tiro
fuori questo è smadonno E va bene così
Non rimanerci secca Eh ci proviamo Sì ci
proviamo un po' di pesetas Ah c'è anche
la Quest vendi tre vipere che me ne fa
come faccio a trovare tre vipere Almeno
non mi ha chiesto di raccogliere i ragni
Beh già quello Oh che bella un'altra
chiesa Sono proprio contento eh
[Applauso]
la chiesa ce l'ho fatta di nuovo al
centro del villaggio ragazzi vediamo se
riusciamo Ah guarda qua oh chi è
chi cazzo Ah c'è uno che scava scava sì
che io mi faccio i cazzi miei
la polvere la switch ha un sacco di
polvere della sua ragazzi non la sto
usando perché finché è un foro è un fido
Destriero anche Aspetta che non vedo un
cazzo Lyon la torcia usa la quella merda
di torcia non vedo niente Cioè mi sa che
si sono accorti di me anche dall'altra
parte Insomma Porca [__] e tu potevi
continuare a farti i cazzi tuoi Cioè non
ho capito
minchia Gli shottati Comunque ragazzi eh
permesso Scusate eh qua Mi serve capire
un attimo
cosa c'è c'è un'altra chiesa ci avete in
stop minchia di posto pure pure sbarrato
e stai calmo
La chiesa è sigillata perfetto negativo
ancora nulla ma di certo si sono
preoccupati di chiudere bene Mmm capisco
e Posso anche immaginare perché
l'abbiamo fatto Ah lei si trova qui è
sicuro riuscirò a entrare
quando uno Chiudo qua dentro
va Potresti anche provare a fare tipo
Uncharted tipo scalare le cose vabbè Mi
serve quel simbolo lì che non ho quindi
sono quattro mani e uno stemma con
quattro mani devo andare a trovarlo non
so come non so dove ma in tutto questo
la zia che mi ha salvato il culo prima
nel capitolo prima dove minchia è
sono entrato Ah no non è la chiesa
questa questa troppo bello Posso anche
salvare la partita Eccola qua la foto
della zia
tenetela Chiusa nella chiesa fino
all'orario stabilito è qua quindi
perfetto Ciao ha preso lo zio Lion
bravissimo
e dammi una bussola gigantesca tipo
Diamante giallo va bene questo secondo
me lo vendo a un miliardo e mezzo questa
qua
ua rogna a è scritto tutto strappato una
rogna proveniente dall'esterno e qui in
cerca della ragazza sarei io trasferita
nella chiesa e state in attesa di
ulteriori ordini dal nostro Signore nel
frattempo potete la ben chiusa la porta
la chiave sarà costruita nella caverna
sullo lato opposto del Lago il mostro si
occuperà dello stupido intruso ok
il lago Speriamo che non ci siano altre
sorprese Eh beh c'è da parati col mostro
quindi figurati c'è gente raga la sento
me ne fotto e ci vado uguale perché
tanto ormai ho rotto il cazzo che la
metà bassa quindi rompiamolo
definitivamente attenzione
l'ago Grazie ma l'unica via era questa
non è che c'ha chissà quali alternative
attenzione qua sento People
Oh merda
ha pure dovevo farglielo saltare in
faccia Adesso ci provo dai
stronzo
muori
China tocco allegria Macarena ma morirai
prima o poi
è morto mi sa Salve
minchia come ho fatto a schivarla non lo
so Venite venite ragazzi che c'ho la
sorpresa
Ecco qua fatto Non è che c'è il tizio
C'è ancora un altro tizio Madonna raga
che esco casino qua
dai Dove stai stai Dove stai Lo zio
Mamma
devo fare in tempo a farli fuori prima
che si trasformino perché poi è un dito
nel culo
Oh chi cazzo
Oh
Ma chi è mannaggia a tua madre ma chi è
che è uscito uno dietro ma [__]
Ma dove cazzo sei uscito tu
testa di culo Guarda proviamo a
lanciafreccia ragazzi non ho ancora
provato vediamo com'è non ho capito
quanto leva la freccia Secondo me leva
abbastanza eh
sì quello che hai detto tu mannaggia al
cazzo Ah aspetta SPE quanta gente che
c'è perché deve essere un bordello ogni
volta
beh
veloce veloce quanto tempo quanto tempo
Sì ma Dovete morire ragazzi però
non muoiono ma me le fa riprendere
quelle frecce sì o Ah siete scemi
Vabbè dai Meno male
tutto a posto
Mi ha recuperato la freccia funziona
ragazzi utile Beh comunque non è male se
me lo potenzio Secondo me le aveva un
sacco raga Eh secondo me potrebbe essere
utile Lancia una freccia poi non lo so
perché più avanti nel gioco diventa un
po' complicato quindi sarebbe opportuno
tipo potenziarmi la pistola fino alla
fine già c'è gente poco raccomandabile
se entro nelle miniere è finita però
vabbè coltello da cucina
ne sto trovando un sacco di coltelli da
cucina Eh però sono One shot Il problema
è quello permesso sono U Strunz che
vuole prendere vuole fare fuori tutti mi
conviene non andare proprio dritto come
un treno perché secondo me
Ma quante queste ci sono in sto gioco
Madonna un'altra queste secondarie
pazzesco
devi essere bello grosso per usare
questo sicuro non lo uso io poi però
vabbè se lo usate voi fatemelo sapere
[Applauso]
Vabbè dai uno è meglio che niente ai
cani cani cani cani merda merda merda
merda
Meno male che non reggono tanti cani
ragazzi che c'è solo lui c'era
No infatti
due no ok
Non è morto è morto Ok Perfetto Mauro
c'è un rumore ah ah Minchia raga Minchia
Minchia
mi sono ricordato adesso No ragazzi
questa porta Non voi non volete che io
Apra questa porta però per adesso
andiamo avanti
ci vuole questa chiave qua strana che
ancora non ho capito
cioè il mercato Madonna mia sto mercante
me lo trovo ogni tre metri incredibile
Allora aspetta
Perfetto Mi fai salvare la dov'è ma non
c'è
Ecco c'hai proprio il negozio qua si
apre questo si è aperto Eccolo lo zio
tipo il negozio del mercante
come sei oh Dio santo Benedetto
potrei chiedere in prestito solo perché
c'è un tizio amico mio che sta dietro
una porta quando vendi un'arma che
potenziato riceverai indietro quasi
tutti i soldi che avrei investito non ce
ne sono fregatura amico facciamo tifo
per te Vuoi farmi vendere armi per
comprare armi nuove Sì certo C'è un
ascensore Addirittura Ma che che cazzo
Ah no questo è il poligono se non
sbaglio credo che questo sia il poligono
Se non erro
me lo ricordavo ragazzi
scambio i gettoni con i ciondoli Sì ho
capito i proiettili che uso sono quelli
miei
Sì ma se sono i miei proiettili mi posso
anche provare ma è mai Ah no Ci sono
colpi infiniti Ok perfetto
Ma quelli bianchi non sono pirati giusto
perfetto
Madonna ma che ansia Raga ma sul serio
[Musica]
Ma poi quanto è grosso sto caricatore
Ragazzi c'è incredibile
non è merda merda l'ho detto anch'io
è finito Ho vinto
Beh dai ragazzi li ho fatti tutti Ho
preso un po' di punti che mi serviranno
non ho capito bene che mi servono
Speriamo di aver vinto abbastanza è
diventato Sea of thieves Comunque per un
attimo di studi d'argento puoi ottenere
un ciondolo a distribuire distributore
alle probabilità in base aumentano
quindi va culo ok e mi dà 200 cos'è che
mi dà il ciondolo
fanatico con balestra probabilità bonus
di creazione delle frecce 20 per cento
Ah sono i ciondoli che posso usare per
la valigetta Ok
dammene un raro testa di culo un raro
salute del presidente con le piante
verdi più 10 Vabbè dai non fa schifo
meglio che un cazzotto non in bocca
Vabbè va bene così meglio che un
cazzotto di Lion in bocca soprattutto
Vabbè ragazzi sono soddisfatto sono
soddisfatto per andare peggio eh grazie
grazie visto che la pausa è finita
finita è più o meno ah vediamo se mi
rifaccio a mettere praticamente
valigetta
sinistra centro Ah e poi puoi mettere
uno anche a destra Vabbè e qua sopra
ragazzi cos'è che c'è c'è una porta
che si apre Tra l'altro Va bene dai per
andare avanti Ok allora mi sa che devo
andare di qua Madonna ma che è Ecco
il castello cazzo è Game of Thrones Game
of Thrones
Perché Ah ma siamo già là oh siamo al
lago ma fortissimi ma fortissimi Oh c'è
anche il binocolo erbinocolo e
dall'altra parte che c'è gente Salve
non li vedo molto Ferrati questi cioè
ehm che sta facendo a pescare Ah perché
non Stanno pescando stanno buttando
cadaveri senza testa nel lago bene
cazzo perché lo fanno vi chiederei vi
chiederete perché c'è da da mangiare a
il pesciolino rosso che è questo
Beh è più grosso del mio cane quello
sicuramente Dov'è la barchetta non c'è
più vabbè Questo è il nostro del Lago me
lo ricordavo ragazzi però il timing è
stato perfetto Comunque io vista sta
scena non c'è qua c'è gente sicuro
perché è pieno di risorse e cose Quindi
qua c'è gente probabilmente Uscirà da
qua però in tutto questo il carburante
della barca è conservato insieme a
quello del generatore all'interno del
capanno di trattamento dell'allevamento
pesci prendi solo quello che ti serve va
bene E no perché stavo dicendo appunto
devono far fuori quello zio che vi ho
detto prima che però è chiuso dentro il
dentro L'Arena ma vediamo dopo ragazzi
eh Perché per adesso Madonna che casino
Porca [__]
tutto ok raga Eh sono vivo
Ragazzi c'è gente però non la vedo la
sento e basta Oh salve
No ti prego lui no ti prego lui no ti
prego ti guarda Aspetta
di merda
muori
Minchia che botta Oh ok
[Musica]
Mica è morto subito stavolta ragazzi il
fucile a pompa potenziato fa la
differenza a quanto pare fa la
differenza
Ma chi cazzo siete
Porca [__] Ahia ahia Aspettami culo per
adesso comunque posso dire di aver fatto
la differenza col fucile a pompa vedete
che serve però io mi terrei i colpi
perché tra un po' mi servono Buono Meno
male che ho fatto che c'erano i colpi
prima perché minchia quali finisco tutti
secondo me ragazzi
andiamo a far fuori fallo fuori fallo
fallo fallo fallo fallo fallo
che questo si alza è un disastro Bene
bene così
Allora è nata meglio del previsto per
andare peggio Bisogna andare molto
peggio E comunque tutto sto casino perde
il carburante schifoso eh Ce n'è anche
per dire Oh chi è questo Ah zio
Vabbè Nel dubbio le palle ma di questo
tornano indietro Va bene Ah c'è un'altra
bomba qua attenzione eh
poi fai piano perché qua non lo so non
lo sorpassi sto punto ok Nice
perfetto
e poi Qua c'è una porta che non mi torna
a Minchia
perfetto
giorno
al carburante Eccolo qua
adesso che lo prendo esco fuori e c'è la
Madonna io ve lo dico già lo so Me lo
sento Prendi prendi prendi prendi sembra
il carburante quello di la tanica è la
stessa di venerdì 13 Mo esco c'è di
tutto cioè proprio inguardabile fuori
Scommetto No Minchia raga c'è di tutto
qua adesso me lo sento
sono in 65 mila raga va bene la tipa
Intanto è arrivata fin qua non si sa
come Vabbè posso riarmarlo la bomba no
non posso
io la volevo buttare di sotto non ci
sono riuscito Però va bene anche così è
molto scenico e ci siamo con il
carburante ragazzi non vedo l'ora guarda
di ficcarlo dentro Proviamo con l'ago
raga perché col lago cioè noi non è non
è una cinematica noi possiamo andare in
giro con la barchetta me lo ricordo sta
cosa
Bravo Nice
e invece una cinematica praticamente
dovrei riuscire a comandarla Almeno così
era in quello originale
io non ci andrei con tutta questa
nonchalance però fai tu Ecco a posto
Va bene intanto Ma sì ma sì ma tanto
guarda te ne sta andando una giusta non
te ne stanno una giusta Quando sei
arrivato qua io no Sì sì questo è il mio
amico
Questo è il mio amico pesciolino piccolo
no Ragazzi comunque
sarebbe utile arpionarlo così ti tiravi
sotto che è una cosa ancora più
jumpscare tra 3 2 1
c'ha la mira peggiore della mia sto
tizio c'è da dire Eh perché comunque sei
impegnato per mancare una bar l'unica
barchetta Che c'è Ecco A proposito Ecco
questa cosa non me la ricordavo però
l'ho detta a caso giuro sconfiggi il
mostro della Mira arpione Lancia Ma io
non ho salvato la partita
se schiatto che cazzo succede Io non ho
salvato quanti Arpioni hai zio se posso
chiedere cioè da un miliardo di Arpioni
Lion complimenti
quanti Arpioni come fai ad avere un
miliardo di Arpioni Lyon Spiegami
come cazzo fai ad avere un miliardo di
Arpioni Ma che boss fai te eh
Meglio almeno non spreco colpi i miei
però Madonna è casino Dov'è il tizio
a posto
Oh merda merda
ma e poi la barchetta è piccola Cioè se
il pulcino vero magari non ha Tiziano
Ecco A posto a posto no
Meno male non m'ha preso come ho fatto
Ah perché basta colpirlo una volta
Minchia Ragazzi sto andando benissimo mo
che ho detto sto stronzata Guarda eh
aspetta l'ho detta la cagata del giorno
ok
avevo detto che sta andando benissimo
Beh Perfetto meno male che sono sincero
nelle cose se si immergesse un attimo
sarei morto basterebbe immergersi
proprio cioè non è che è difficile
ok
Dove sei andato e questo non lo so prova
a seguire l'onda ma non credo
ancora
[Musica]
ti ho scassato il culo Oh
con i miei 65 Arpioni gli ho fatto un
culo così ma bravissimo ma me lo
ricordavo molto più difficile eh
Sinceramente me la ricordavo molto più
efficienza a boss Fight e invece solo
perché avevo 82 Arpioni sulla sulla
barchetta che succede Oh ok È il mal di
mare zio sarà quello che è successo
che
succede che sta che c'è Oh ma perché
mani iniettato le cose ho detto come ho
capito Ho terminato Strange Stranger
non so se ho detto mi piace il Mercante
per esempio qua Comunque è finito
l'episodio però vi sia piaciuto Ragazzi
a me sta piacendo un casino è bellissimo
Si vede che adesso il video Vi è
piaciuto lasciate un mi piace e un
commento su cosa ne pensate
dell'episodio E noi come sempre ci
vediamo ad un prossimo video bella
ragazzi